these highly toxic accidents can't be a
coincidence for the third time within a
few weeks a vehicle with toxic material
on board crashed in a mysterious way
first in Ohio where Train derailed toxic
chemicals sunk into America's water
supply and then they set the spilled
chemicals on fire leading to a giant
mushroom cloud covering the entire area
it's a toxic disaster America hasn't
seen in a long time a few days later
another Train derailed this time in
Houston and now a truck crashed in
Arizona with nitric acid on board a
super corrosive chemical that can cause
severe lung damage a HazMat team had to
clear the area residents living nearby
either had to leave their homes or stay
inside with their ACS shut off who knows
maybe aliens will finally invade so we
can forget about all this click the link
in the pinned comment to watch our full
video on this